You know that bit after a client session, when you want to grab a drink, maybe make yourself some lunch, perhaps eat your dinner or have some wind down time. But as any clinician knows, when you've still got notes to write up, it can feel hard to get on with your day. And sometimes if it's been a really involved session, it can feel like that bit for each client can turn the 50-minute appointment you'd budgeted for into a 75-minute one. And imagine that on repeat for all of your weekly sessions. Well, this episode is brought to you by, write-up and their new AI scribe is a tool built for clinicians who'd quite like their evenings back. Write-up's AI scribe is your in-session companion and works whether you're in-person or remote. It picks up the clinically relevant details and uses them to draft your clinical notes for you.
你知道在结束客户咨询后，你想要喝杯饮料、做顿午餐、吃顿晚餐或者放松一下的那段时间吗？但正如任何临床医生所知，当你还有病历需要整理时，很难继续享受你的生活。有时，如果这是一次非常深入的咨询，原本预算的50分钟预约可能会变成75分钟。想象一下，每周的咨询都这样重复。好吧，本期节目由Write-up赞助，他们新推出的AI记录工具专为那些想找回晚间休息时间的临床医生打造。Write-up的AI记录工具是你咨询时的好伙伴，无论你是面对面还是远程咨询，它都能适用。它会捕捉临床相关的细节，并为你起草临床记录。
And the best bit, it'll do it in the structure you usually use. You read, you tweak, you sign off, done. No more, I'll write it up later, guilt spiral at 9. PM. Writeup is UK-built GDPR compliant and made specifically for healthcare professionals. And because it understands the way we work, not just the way American systems work, I think that like me, you're going to love it. Right now, you can grab your free 30-day trial of write-up, which includes a four-hour free trial with AI scribe. Then you can see how it handles your notes before you commit to anything. Head to writeup.com to give it a go. That's WR.R.R.
最棒的是，它会按照你习惯的结构来完成。你阅读、微调、签字，搞定。再也不会有晚上9点因为“我待会儿再写”而产生的负罪感了。Write-up是英国开发并符合GDPR标准的，专为医疗专业人士设计。因为它了解我们的工作方式，而不仅仅是美国系统的工作方式，我想你会像我一样喜欢它。现在，你可以领取Write-up的30天免费试用，其中包括4小时的AI记录免费试用。在决定购买之前，你可以先看看它如何处理你的记录。前往writeup.com试试看。网址是WR.R.R.
t-e-e-u-p-com and remember to use the code marianne 30 Netflix once said their biggest competitor was sleep and honestly that tells you everything about modern life we live in a world where everything feels important all the time every email every opinion every task every notification competing for our attention and in the middle of all that a lot of people have completely lost sight of what actually matters to them. So in this episode, author Lily Silverton and I explore procrastination, comparison, overwhelm attention and why modern life makes it so hard to prioritise ourselves. I hope you find it really useful if you do like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome to psychology actually. I'm Dr.
t-e-e-u-p-com，记得使用优惠码marianne 30。Netflix曾说他们最大的竞争对手是睡眠，老实说，这道出了现代生活的真相。我们生活在一个一切似乎都时刻重要的世界里：每一封邮件、每一个观点、每一项任务、每一条通知都在争夺我们的注意力。在这一切之中，许多人已经完全忘记了什么才是对自己真正重要的。因此，在本期节目中，我和作家莉莉·西尔弗顿（Lily Silverton）探讨了拖延、比较、过度关注以及为什么现代生活让我们如此难以优先考虑自己。希望你觉得这期节目很有用，如果喜欢，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到《心理学其实》（Psychology Actually）。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士，
Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist and we are welcoming our guest today for today's episode, Lily Silverton, author of Prioritized This. Welcome, Lily. Hi, Marian. Thank you for having me. Thank you for being here. So tell us a little bit about why prioritising anything is a good idea, Lily. Well, we, I think as you very well know, particularly within your work, we live in a very demanding world. We have very demanding lives externally. We have very demanding lives internally in terms of what's going on in our psyches. And we can be made to feel and we can make ourselves to feel as if absolutely everything is important in life or as if we don't quite understand what's important and what's of value and what will benefit us always. And by thinking a little bit more deeply
一位合格的临床心理学家。今天我们欢迎本期节目的嘉宾，畅销书《优先考虑这个》（Prioritized This）的作者莉莉·西尔弗顿。欢迎你，莉莉。嗨，玛丽安。谢谢你邀请我。谢谢你的到来。那么，莉莉，请告诉我们为什么优先考虑任何事情都是个好主意。嗯，我想正如你非常清楚的那样，特别是在你的工作中，我们生活在一个要求极高的世界里。我们在外部有着要求极高的生活，在内心深处，就我们的心理活动而言，也有着要求极高的生活。我们可能会被引导去感觉，或者我们自己让自己感觉，生活中绝对每一件事都很重要，或者我们并不完全理解什么才是重要的、有价值的，以及什么总是对我们有益的。通过更深入地思考
about priorities and prioritizing, I think we can begin to some extent, not entirely, of course, but to some extent to shape the reality that we walk through, both in terms of what we're doing in the world, but also in terms of how we feel internally. Yeah, absolutely. And I have read your book and I've made some notes. I really like it. It's really interesting food for thought.
关于优先级和优先排序，我认为我们可以在一定程度上——当然不是全部——塑造我们所经历的现实，不仅是在我们所做的事情方面，而且是在我们内心的感受方面。是的，绝对是这样。我读过你的书，也做了一些笔记。我真的很喜欢它。它确实提供了非常有趣的思考空间。
And there's a couple of kind of things that really struck me as I read it. And there was a phrase, a wealth of information creates a poverty of attention. And it's like, yeah, it really does, isn't it? Because we're constantly just overstimulated and not really knowing where to attend to. And as a result, maybe doing a pretty rubbish job of everything or most things. It's hard. Yeah.
在阅读时，有几件事真的触动了我。书中有一句话：“信息丰富导致注意力贫乏”。这真是太对了，不是吗？因为我们总是处于过度刺激的状态，不知道该关注哪里。结果，可能在做每一件事或大多数事情时都做得一团糟。这很难。是的。
And I mean, that's an old quote. So that's from the 1971, I think the thinker wrote that. And, God, like if they could see the world today, right? The amount of information that's going on, the severe lack of resources that we have in terms of our attention. And also how much money and effort goes into some of the, so drawing away some of that attention from us, you know, from social media companies. Yeah. And there's two points that are resonating with me from that is that even older, even further back, apparently the Romans had said, got everything moved so quickly and it's really hard to keep up with all this change and all this progress. So this is not a new thing, you know, like humans have said this since humans existed, I guess, you know, since the wheel was invented.
而且，那是一句老话了，我想是1971年的思想家写的。天哪，如果他们能看到今天的世界，对吧？信息量之大，我们在注意力资源方面的严重匮乏。还有，社交媒体公司投入了多少金钱和精力来分散我们的注意力。是的。从那句话中，我有两点感触：甚至更早之前，据说罗马人也说过，一切发展得太快了，很难跟上所有的变化和进步。所以这并不是什么新鲜事，你知道，人类自从存在以来，我想自从轮子被发明以来，就一直在说这些话。
Like, well, this is wild. When I found that out as I was doing the research for the book, I found that such a funny point because we do tend to think that we are so exceptional and that the way we think is so exceptional and so on. And it is, I think people will see this as a big era of change because it has been. But yeah, that, you know, regardless of how humans have lived and how they've been operating, they've always felt that things are moving very fast. Yeah. Yeah. And then the other point is that people and corporations make big money from us having split focus or from us not paying attention to the things that maybe would make us more money or would help us to have better sleep. And there was a company that you mentioned in your book. Tell us, tell us about the
这太疯狂了。当我在为书做研究时发现这一点时，我觉得这很有趣，因为我们确实倾向于认为自己是如此独特，我们的思维方式是如此独特等等。我认为人们会把这看作是一个巨大的变革时代，因为它确实如此。但无论人类如何生活和运作，他们总是觉得事情发展得非常快。是的。是的。另一个观点是，个人和公司通过我们分散的注意力，或者通过我们不关注那些可能让我们赚更多钱或帮助我们获得更好睡眠的事情来赚大钱。你书中提到了一个公司。告诉我们，告诉我们关于
Netflix analogy. What they'd said is their biggest competitor. Yeah, this is Reid Hastings, the CEO or was it, I think it's still CEO now, but was saying that their biggest competitor is sleep. So it is when people, and I check this over and over again to check, did he really say this, or is this, you know, something the internet's made up and it does appear that it's an absolutely legitimate quote. Perhaps said slightly ingest, but as, I mean, as you know, as a clinical psychologist, often the things we say as a joke are the things. we really mean. If people slept less, then Netflix would get more watch hours and, you know, we'd have more money. I should go to that is the issue. Yeah. And it's that autoplay, isn't it,
Netflix的类比。他们说他们最大的竞争对手是睡眠。是的，这是里德·黑斯廷斯（Reid Hastings），也就是CEO，或者我想现在还是CEO，他说他们最大的竞争对手是睡眠。所以，当人们——我反复核实过，他真的这么说过吗，还是互联网编造的——这看起来确实是一个完全合法的引语。也许说得有点开玩笑，但正如你作为临床心理学家所知，我们开玩笑说的话往往是我们真正想表达的。如果人们睡得少，Netflix就会获得更多的观看时长，你知道，我们就会有更多的钱。我应该去看看这个问题。是的，就是那个自动播放，不是吗？
that comes up at the end after, you know, by the time you find your remote, sometimes sometimes it's starting playing and then, you know, that sunk cost fallacy, oh, we might as well continue now, or we've already seen what happens next. Like, yeah, that really blew my mind. So, yeah, thinking about a couple of your chapters, if that's all right, to think about what might be really helpful for our listeners and our viewers. I really like the stuff on procrastination, and that maybe speaks volumes about me. Why is procrastination so tricky for us as humans? There's many reasons, but one of the most important, and I speak about quite a lot in the book, is we have, as I mean, again, as you well know, conflicting desires at all times. And in terms of our brain
在最后出现，你知道，当你找到遥控器时，有时它已经开始播放了，然后，你知道，那种沉没成本谬误，“哦，我们现在不妨继续看下去”，或者我们已经看到了接下来会发生什么。这真的让我大开眼界。所以，想谈谈你的几个章节，如果可以的话，看看对我们的听众和观众有什么帮助。我真的很喜欢关于拖延的内容，这可能说明了我自己。为什么拖延对我们人类来说如此棘手？原因有很多，但其中最重要的一点，我在书中谈了很多，就是我们——正如你非常清楚的那样——时刻都有相互冲突的欲望。就我们的大脑
and the way it operates, we have one desire, right, to plan for the future and think of future me and anticipate and take the actions that are going to support our long-term objectives and aims. And then we have this other network of conversations in our brain that says, don't do that at all. You know what you should do. You should do exactly what you want right now. And that's going to be fucking amazing. So you should do what's going to feel really good now. And in the book I talk about like it's really just two quite opposing forces, perhaps like a tabloid versus a broadshe editor, which feels very relevant at the moment, having just, you know, gone through the elections. And that these things fundamentally, these pathways in your brain fundamentally want different
以及它的运作方式而言，我们有一种欲望，对吧，为未来做计划，考虑未来的自己，预见并采取支持我们长期目标和目的的行动。然后我们大脑中还有另一套对话网络，它说：“根本不要那样做。你知道你应该做什么。你应该做你现在想做的任何事。那会爽翻天的。所以你应该做那些现在感觉很好的事情。”在书中，我谈到这就像是两种截然相反的力量，也许就像小报编辑和宽幅报纸编辑，考虑到刚刚经历的选举，这感觉非常相关。这些大脑中的路径从根本上想要不同的
things and that often the short term wins out. And when it comes to procrastination, that means that we put off perhaps doing the things now that we know we should do and we seek instead to sort of feel better in the moment. And I think the big thing with procrastination is that everyone thinks it's a time management problem and in part it is absolutely and it's also a habit of time management, mismanagement, let's say. It's also completely and utterly fucking normal. So everyone procrastinates to some extent. I procrastinate and that's a whole chapter in the book. You know, we all procrastinate. I know lots of people who write about it and they still procrastinate. It's very normal.
东西，而且往往是短期欲望获胜。当谈到拖延时，这意味着我们推迟了现在应该做的事情，转而寻求在当下感觉更好。我认为拖延症最大的问题在于，每个人都认为这是一个时间管理问题，在某种程度上确实如此，而且这也是一种时间管理习惯，或者说是管理不善。它也完全是极其正常的。所以每个人都会在一定程度上拖延。我也拖延，书中有一整章都在讲这个。你知道，我们都会拖延。我认识很多写这个话题的人，他们自己也拖延。拖延一点点是非常正常、
natural and healthy to procrastinate a little bit. It's more when it starts impacting your life. But that we think it's a time management problem and it is. But there's also this huge element of emotional management and how we are, you know, if we don't want to do something by not doing it, we make ourselves feel better. Because if the idea of doing something feels uncomfortable and feels hard or feels like, say it's a big project, a big personal project that you've wanted to start for ages, but you keep putting it off and putting it off. You know, perhaps there's that fear of failure. Perhaps there's that perfectionism, perfectionist side of you that's scared to do something,
自然且健康的。只有当它开始影响你的生活时，才是个问题。但我们认为这是一个时间管理问题，它确实是。但其中还有一个巨大的情感管理因素，以及我们是如何——你知道，如果我们不想做某事，通过不做它，我们让自己感觉更好。因为如果做某事的想法让你感到不舒服、困难，或者感觉像是一个大项目，一个你一直想开始但却不断推迟的大型个人项目。你知道，也许有对失败的恐惧。也许是你身上那个完美主义的一面，害怕做某事，
scared you won't do it perfectly. And so you put it off. And so by putting it off, you are assuaging. Is that the way is it? Aswaging? I pronounce that correctly. Those feelings. You know, you are making yourself feel better.
害怕你做得不够完美。所以你推迟了它。通过推迟，你是在缓解——是这样发音吗？缓解？我发音正确吗？那些感受。你知道，你是在让自己感觉更好。
You are self-soothing. and we don't really acknowledge that enough when it comes to procrastination. We're just saying to people, you know, do X and Y. And of course, your work is so fundamentally incredible on this stuff because it's about getting people to dig in and say, okay, but what are the emotions that you're trying to avoid here? Yeah, and I love the idea. So I've got Trello board, which is how I run everything. I run, aside from my clinical work with clients, I don't use Trello for that.
你是在自我安抚。当谈到拖延时，我们并没有真正充分认识到这一点。我们只是告诉人们，“做这个和那个”。当然，你在这些方面的研究非常不可思议，因为它在于让人们深入挖掘并说：“好吧，但你在这里试图避免的情绪是什么？”是的，我喜欢这个想法。我有一个Trello看板，这是我管理一切的方式。除了与客户的临床工作外，我不把Trello用于那方面。
yeah, like all my podcast stuff, anything I've got to write. If it's not on Trello, it's not happening, which is like a project management software for anyone's not familiar with that. But I will look at that when I've got some time and I'll be like, what am I going to do now? And I'm not going to do that now. I'm going to do that now instead.
是的，比如我所有的播客内容，任何我需要写的东西。如果它不在Trello上，它就不会发生，对于不熟悉的人来说，这是一种项目管理软件。但我有时间的时候会看它，我会想：“我现在要做什么？”然后我会想：“我现在不做那个。我改做那个。”
And in your book, you speak about something, I think, called affective forecasting, which is such a powerful and important idea. It's not something I'd heard of before, actually. But it's the idea that we'll look at what's ever on our to do list and be like, well, I'll much prefer to do that a different day. Or we anticipate that it won't be as difficult on a different day. And of course, you know, largely it's probably going to be the same as if we did it today. Talk to us about that, Lily.
在你的书中，你谈到了一种叫做“情感预测”（affective forecasting）的东西，这是一个非常强大且重要的概念。实际上，我以前没听说过。但它的意思是，我们会看着待办事项清单上的任何事情，然后想：“嗯，我更愿意在另一天做那个。”或者我们预料到在另一天做它不会那么困难。当然，你知道，很大程度上它可能和今天做是一样的。跟我们谈谈这个，莉莉。
Yeah, effective forecasting is so fascinating because our brain, as you said, essentially thinks to itself, present me doesn't want to do this. Present me right now in this moment doesn't. But next week, me is going to be a completely different kind of person and that person is really going to want to do it. And that's why, I mean, there's other reasons that play as well, but it's why we'll do things like not start a new habit on a Wednesday, but say, I'll wait till Monday because we have that idea. First of all, that future me is going to really want to do that and be really great at it. And the version of me on a Monday morning is going to be a different version than the me on a Wednesday morning as well. But generally, you know, you are still you. I am still me in the same
是的，情感预测非常迷人，因为正如你所说，我们的大脑本质上会对自己说：“现在的我不想要做这个。此时此刻的我不想要做。但下周的我将是一个完全不同的人，那个人真的会想要做它。”这就是为什么——虽然还有其他原因——我们会做一些事情，比如不在周三开始一个新习惯，而是说：“我等到周一吧。”因为我们有那种想法。首先，未来的我会真的想要做那个，并且会做得很好。而且周一早上的那个版本的我，也会和周三早上的那个版本的我不同。但总的来说，你知道，你仍然是你。我仍然是我，在同一个
version. And so while you may have a slightly more motivation at various different points, depending on other circumstances and things that are going on in your brain or your life, having this idea that future you is going to do something a lot better or is going to want to do something is fundamentally wrong. It really is. And I think just knowing yourself, So there's knowing if you're going out on a big weekend or you're going away with certain people that maybe, yeah, don't schedule that for the Monday afterwards. So there's knowing yourself and knowing what's reasonable. But also, yeah, like if I don't want to do this task now, I'm probably not going to want to do it next week either. So then it's how would we think about our priorities?
版本里。所以，虽然根据其他情况以及大脑或生活中发生的事情，你在不同的时间点可能会有稍微多一点的动力，但认为未来的你会做得更好或者会想要做某事，从根本上是错误的。确实如此。我认为只要了解自己就行了。所以，如果你知道你要去度过一个盛大的周末，或者你要和某些人一起出去玩，也许——是的，不要把任务安排在之后的周一。所以要了解自己，知道什么是合理的。但同时，是的，如果我现在不想做这个任务，下周我也很可能不想做。那么我们该如何考虑我们的优先级呢？
Is that really important to us? Should we think about reprioritizing that? So we've got more on our plate of what feels more abundantly within our comfortable, wheelhouse or that we want to do. I guess life isn't always that simple, but is that like a clear communication if we're always like, no, no, don't want to do that, don't want to do that? Well, I think that we put things off because it makes us feel better. But then if we actually think about it, a lot of the things that we put off, the pain and stress that they cause us later down the line by pulling them off is always actually stronger and more pronounced than the relief, say,
那对我们来说真的重要吗？我们是否应该考虑重新排列优先级？这样我们就能在盘子里装更多我们觉得更舒适、更擅长或者更想做的事情。我想生活并不总是那么简单，但如果我们总是说“不，不，不想做那个，不想做那个”，这是否是一种清晰的沟通？嗯，我认为我们推迟事情是因为它让我们感觉更好。但如果我们真正思考一下，我们推迟的很多事情，通过推迟它们而在以后给我们造成的痛苦和压力，总是比我们
that we get from not doing it in the moment. So I think that's one thing to start to think about for yourself in terms of how, in terms of emotional management and how you are experiencing the world. Obviously, we're not going to do things perfectly if we never will. But thinking of this in terms of, well, A, if this is really important to me, how can I make this more important?
在当下不做它们所获得的解脱感要强烈和显著得多。所以我认为这是你需要开始为自己思考的一点，关于情感管理以及你如何体验这个世界。显然，如果我们永远做不到，我们也不会完美地完成事情。但从这个角度思考，嗯，A，如果这对我很重要，我怎样才能让它变得更重要？
How can I make it so that I act on it? What are the barriers that I need to move through? say it's a big personal project we're talking about at this point. What are the barriers that I need to move through? Is it that I need to work on my fear of failure? Is it that I need to work maybe with a partner, you know, not on the project itself, but on just getting things done? So we call it body doubling in coaching where you just do something with someone else instead,
我怎样才能让它变得让我采取行动？我需要克服哪些障碍？假设我们现在谈论的是一个大型个人项目。我需要克服哪些障碍？是因为我需要克服对失败的恐惧吗？是因为我需要和伙伴一起工作吗？你知道，不是在项目本身上，而是在完成事情上？我们在教练中称之为“身体加倍”（body doubling），你只是和别人一起做某事，
just to get you there. And then sometimes that action can lead to that motivation and that can create some momentum. Do I need to? And then if it's something, say, your taxes was something that you put off. So it's not maybe a big important project, but something that's more urgent, thinking about, okay, but how can I break this down? Because it's a very big task and it feels intimidating and say, like, really not one with numbers, then it's going to feel very intimidating to your brain.
只是为了让你开始。然后有时那种行动可以带来动力，并创造一些势头。我需要吗？然后如果它是某件事，比如你的税收是你推迟的事情。所以它可能不是一个大的重要项目，而是一件更紧急的事情，思考：“好吧，但我怎样才能把它分解？”因为它是一个非常大的任务，感觉很吓人，而且假设你真的不擅长数字，那么它对你的大脑来说会感觉非常吓人。
And your brain is going to shy away from that because one of your brain's main priorities, aside from staying alive, is conserving energy because that helps it stay alive. So tasks that take a lot of effort, use up a lot of energy. And so sometimes your brain will shy away from that, particularly if you have habits around shying away from things which are difficult. So it's about how can you break things down and make them more manageable for your brain? How can you make it so that you don't get that visceral reaction of like, absolutely not let me do something else? I'm going to ignore that thing on the to-do list until it's so big that it's actually causing a lot of stress in my life. Yeah, because our brains are clever things.
你的大脑会回避它，因为你大脑的主要优先级之一，除了保持生存之外，就是节约能量，因为这有助于它生存。所以需要大量努力的任务会消耗大量能量。因此，有时你的大脑会回避它，特别是如果你有回避困难事物的习惯。所以关键在于你如何分解事物，让它们对你的大脑来说更易于管理？你如何做到不产生那种“绝对不行，让我做点别的”的本能反应？我打算忽略待办事项清单上的那件事，直到它变得如此之大，以至于它实际上给我的生活造成了很大的压力。是的，因为我们的大脑是很聪明的。
You know, they're trying to always be averse to pain and stress and move away from that. And so if it feels really big and really awful, it makes sense that we're going to look for, you know, easier options. But yeah, like I like the idea of in the book that you talk about, maybe don't do the whole thing. You know, start 10 minutes. And then because when we do that, I mean, how many times have we done something? We were like, oh, actually, it wasn't that bad. It wasn't that bad. So just make a start.
你知道，它们总是试图回避痛苦和压力，并远离它们。所以如果它感觉非常大且非常糟糕，我们寻找更容易的选择是有道理的。但是的，我喜欢你在书中提到的想法，也许不要做整件事。你知道，先做10分钟。然后因为当我们这样做时——我的意思是，我们有多少次做过某事，然后想：“哦，其实，它没那么糟。它没那么糟。”所以只要开始就行了。
And then you might find that it kind of flows more easily. And then if it doesn't, at least you've made a start as well. And then you know that actually it is quite a challenging task. And so you might need more time than you thought you did versus if you leave it till the last minute, you start it. It's actually quite hard. And then you're a bit fucked because you don't actually have the time to do the project or whatever it is. Was it for the procrastination topic that you spoke about the four quadrants? and breaking things up. Guide us through that.
然后你可能会发现它流动得更顺畅了。如果不行，至少你已经开始了。然后你知道它确实是一个相当具有挑战性的任务。所以你可能需要比你想象中更多的时间，而不是如果你把它留到最后一分钟，你才开始。它实际上相当困难。然后你就有点惨了，因为你实际上没有时间去完成项目或其他什么。你谈到拖延话题时提到的四个象限是什么？以及分解事物。引导我们了解一下。
So that's called the Eisenhower matrix or the priorities matrix, which is just very convenient for me as opposed to something I named. And you divide your tasks from your to-do list, and that might be like your short-term daily to-do list, but maybe your greater to-do list as well in terms of the things you want to do with your life. And you sort them into four quadrants according to whether something is urgent, and important whether something is not urgent but still important whether something is urgent but not important or whether something is not urgent and not important and then you can sort of work
那被称为艾森豪威尔矩阵（Eisenhower matrix）或优先级矩阵，对我来说这很方便，而不是我自己命名的。你把你待办事项清单上的任务分类，这可能是你短期的每日待办事项清单，但也可能是你生活中想要做的更宏大的待办事项清单。你根据某事是否紧急、重要，将它们分为四个象限：是否紧急但重要，是否不紧急但重要，是否紧急但不重要，或者是否不紧急且不重要。然后你可以
through and see if something is urgent and important you need to do that thing right now so that's one going to be on the list of things you absolutely shouldn't put off if something is not urgent and not important then there's the question of like why is it on there in the first place and then you've got the tasks which maybe have less urgency but are really important and that could be where there's personal project type things for all and those are the things that always get shoved down the list and shove down the list because they're not urgent that they might be really important to you and then again that question from before of how can you bring more urgency to it so that you know you can do the things you can prioritize the projects and things that are really truly
逐一处理，看看如果某事既紧急又重要，你需要现在就做那件事，所以那将是绝对不应该推迟的清单上的第一项。如果某事既不紧急也不重要，那么问题就是为什么它会出现在那里。然后你还有那些可能紧急程度较低但非常重要的任务，这可能是个人项目类型的事情，而这些总是被推到清单的最底层，因为它们不紧急，但它们可能对你非常重要。然后再次回到之前的问题：你如何为它带来更多的紧迫感，以便你知道你可以做这些事情，你可以优先考虑那些真正对你
important to you and then when you think about the other quadrant which is maybe not so grandly important but quite urgent. So that might be like admin-y stuff. That for those I always recommend that instead of doing it one by one, so that's admin or bills or whatever, rather than doing it immediately when it comes in, you can group them together and do them once a week or twice a week or once a day, depending on the type of work and life you have. And that you're not constantly drawing from your attention and energy bank that you've got in your head and you can use some of your focus and attention for the more important things and then you can group those little things together and you'll get all those dopamine hits you know the reason we like doing those little
真正重要的项目和事情。然后当你考虑另一个象限时，也就是可能没那么宏大重要但相当紧急的事情。那可能就像行政类工作。对于那些，我总是建议不要一个接一个地做，所以那是行政工作或账单什么的，而不是在它们进来时立即做，你可以把它们归类在一起，每周做一次、两次或每天一次，取决于你的工作和生活类型。这样你就不会不断地从你脑子里的注意力和能量库中提取，你可以把一些专注力和注意力用于更重要的事情，然后你可以把那些小事情归类在一起，你会得到所有的多巴胺奖励。你知道，我们喜欢快速做那些小
things quickly is because when you tick something off your to-do list you get a dopamine hit in your brain your brain likes that chemical and and so it's always going to seek that out and it's going to seek out those small hits um and so what you want to do is kind of fight against that slight and group them together. So you still get that hit, but you also weighed through the discomfort of maybe doing the bigger tasks that need to be done
事情的原因是，当你从待办事项清单上勾掉某事时，你的大脑会获得多巴胺奖励，你的大脑喜欢那种化学物质，所以它总是会寻求那种奖励，它会寻求那些小的奖励。所以你想做的是对抗那种倾向，把它们归类在一起。这样你仍然能得到那种奖励，但你也克服了可能做需要完成的更大任务的不适感，
and keeping your focus and attention on them rather than let me be split the whole time by smaller little things. And that's, you know, put your phone on, do not disturb when you're working so that you're not constantly, oh, I better reply to that WhatsApp from my kids school quickly and so on.
并保持你的专注力和注意力在它们身上，而不是让我在整个过程中被更小的事情分散。而且，你知道，工作时把手机调成“请勿打扰”，这样你就不会不断地想：“哦，我最好快点回复孩子学校的那个WhatsApp”等等。
You know, you want the urgent stuff, the truly urgent stuff to get through. but it's also a really big point of remembering, so I'm going on a bit now, of remembering that other people's urgent is not your urgent. Yeah, that's so important, isn't it? It's so important and we so often forget it and I do the same. And I'm not saying for anyone listening that your boss says something's urgent
你知道，你希望紧急的事情，真正紧急的事情通过。但这也是一个非常重要的点，要记住——我现在有点跑题了——要记住别人的紧急不是你的紧急。是的，那太重要了，不是吗？这太重要了，我们经常忘记它，我也一样。我并不是说对于任何听众来说，如果你的老板说某事很紧急，
and you decide it's not. Don't, you'll probably just lose your job after a while if you work like that. However, just thinking, you know, It's everyone's the main character in their life and everyone is moving through assuming that people are going to move and respond, hopefully move and respond in the ways that they want. And it's our job sometimes to make sure that we are not sacrificing who we are to those bigger personalities or bigger characters who maybe it feels like place more importance on stuff. And so we're understanding.
而你决定它不紧急。别那样做，如果你那样工作，你可能会丢掉工作。然而，只要思考一下，你知道，每个人都是他们生活中的主角，每个人都在行动，假设人们会按照他们想要的方式移动和响应。有时我们的工作是确保我们没有为了那些可能觉得把事情看得更重要的大人物或大角色而牺牲我们自己。所以我们理解。
you know what, it's not urgent that I respond to that email from that particular colleague today. I can leave that until tomorrow. That is not urgent on my plate and I need to prioritise and think what is because otherwise you're always going to be responding to other people's demands and timetables and ways of being rather than understanding what's truly important to you and how you're going to move your own life forward. Yeah, I think before I became a parent, I was very much able to flex and probably just create more time in my day or maybe have shorter breaks to be able to get other people's changing priorities flexed for. So yeah, your boss comes along, your manager wants something done.
你知道吗，今天回复那个特定同事的邮件并不紧急。我可以把它留到明天。那在我的盘子里并不紧急，我需要优先考虑并思考什么才是紧急的，否则你总是会响应别人的需求、时间表和生活方式，而不是理解什么对你真正重要，以及你将如何推动自己的生活前进。是的，我想在我成为父母之前，我非常能够灵活变通，可能只是在一天中创造更多时间，或者可能有更短的休息时间来适应别人不断变化的优先级。所以，是的，你的老板来了，你的经理想要完成某事。
And I think certainly now I'm a parent, I can't always just do that. And so I think something can be really powerful is to say, actually, yeah, if this is urgent, and this is important, you can be like, to your manager or your boss, can you help me look at all the other bits I've already got to work out maybe what doesn't need to be done as quickly today by this week? Because I definitely can do that, but I can't then do all these other things as well, because that would be a well-being detriment to yourself.
我想现在我成了父母，我不能总是那样做。所以我认为有一件事可能非常强大，那就是说：“其实，是的，如果这很紧急，而且这很重要，你可以对你的经理或老板说：‘你能帮我看看我已经有的其他工作，看看今天或本周内可能不需要那么快完成的事情吗？因为我绝对可以做那个，但我不能同时做所有这些其他事情，因为那会对你自己的健康造成损害。’”
Yeah, absolutely. And I wrote this in something recently, I can't remember that it was an article or a newsletter, but I wrote about this idea of if someone comes to you, with another thing to put on your plate, that trying to go back to them and saying, I've got these three priorities, which one should go first, that you go back to your manager. And so it depends on the type of manager you have, but I think often if you do that when, you know, I work with loads of companies, if you do that with confidence, then that shows assertiveness
是的，绝对是这样。我最近在某处写过这个，我不记得是文章还是通讯了，但我写了这个想法：如果有人带着另一件事来找你，想加到你的盘子里，试着回到他们身边说：“我有这三个优先级，哪一个应该先做？”你回到你的经理那里。这取决于你拥有的经理类型，但我认为如果你自信地这样做——你知道，我和很多公司合作——那么这表现出自信，
and it shows that you are considering and thinking things through and not trying to take too much on. If you have a completely toxic boss who's very challenging to work with, it probably won't work as well. But if you have a, you know, receptive smart boss who understands that you want your employees to be prioritising their work and not trying to do everything all at once because if everything's a priority, nothing becomes a priority. Nothing has done that well. Then I think that approach is really, really successful. Yeah. And, you know, you might be like, but they must already know all these things I've got on my plate. And it's again just thinking, actually, we are the main player in our own lives.
并且表明你在考虑和思考事情，而不是试图承担太多。如果你有一个非常糟糕、很难共事的有毒老板，它可能不会那么有效。但如果你有一个接受能力强、聪明的老板，他明白你希望员工优先考虑他们的工作，而不是试图一次性做所有事情——因为如果每一件事都是优先级，那么什么都不是优先级。什么都做得不好。那么我认为这种方法非常、非常成功。是的。而且，你知道，你可能会想：“但他们一定已经知道我盘子里的所有这些事情了。”这又回到了思考，其实，我们是我们自己生活中的主角。
Everyone else might just think we're going to advocate for ourselves or they're so consumed with what's on their own to do list. They're just not thinking about what was already on ours. So it's okay to self-advocate and to kind of bring that up to them so long as they are kind of relatively speaking, a decent human, hopefully. Okay. So we've done all these things. We've kicked procrastination to, you know, to touch as much as that. possible. And we've done the things. But then of course, you know, we're then comparing ourselves to our colleagues, how they've done it. We're comparing ourselves to others on
其他人可能只是认为我们会为自己辩护，或者他们太沉迷于自己的待办事项清单了。他们只是没有考虑我们清单上已经有的东西。所以只要他们相对来说是一个体面的人，希望如此，为自己辩护并向他们提出这一点是可以的。好吧。所以我们已经完成了所有这些事情。我们已经尽可能地把拖延症抛到九霄云外了。我们已经完成了这些事情。但当然，你知道，我们然后把自己和同事比较，看他们是怎么做的。我们把自己和社交媒体上的其他人比较，
social media that seem to be having a better time or have got more followers or more engagement or more likes. And we've got this whole comparisonitis, which then can equally well really, really scupper us, can't it, Lily? Yeah. Comparison is such a huge topic for everyone, myself included, you know, as I say in the book, I am my first student, you know, I imagine perhaps it's, you know, you don't go into this kind of work unless you need the support in the first place yourself. When it comes to comparison, the big key that I found for myself and for the people that I work with is not trying to never compare again. So if you try to never compare, I think you just fail slightly because we are.
他们似乎过得更好，或者有更多的粉丝、更多的互动或更多的点赞。我们有这种“比较综合症”（comparisonitis），这同样会让我们陷入困境，不是吗，莉莉？是的，比较对每个人来说都是一个巨大的话题，包括我自己，你知道，正如我在书中所说，我是我自己的第一个学生，你知道，我想也许，你知道，除非你首先自己需要支持，否则你不会从事这种工作。当谈到比较时，我为自己和与我一起工作的人发现的关键不是试图永远不再比较。所以如果你试图永远不比较，我想你只是稍微失败了，因为我们是。
are, I don't want to say, we're biologically wired to compare, to want to understand how we are doing compared to the people around us. We have social brains. Our brains developed within social conditions and around and in response to other people and what they were doing in life. So that is really, really ingrained in us. And trying to not do it is a little bit, little bit like trying to push away any feeling. You know, if you push away some sadness, it's going to come up in some weird and not wonderful ways later down the line. And I think it's similar with comparison that we need to accept it,
我们是——我不想说——我们天生就是为了比较而生的，想要了解我们与周围的人相比做得如何。我们有社交大脑。我们的大脑是在社会条件下，在周围人以及对他们生活中所做事情的反应中发展起来的。所以这确实深深地植根于我们心中。试图不这样做有点像试图推开任何感觉。你知道，如果你推开一些悲伤，它以后会在一些奇怪且不美妙的方式中出现。我认为比较也是如此，我们需要接受它，
that we need to say, you know, I am a comparative creature by nature. Some people will be more so than others. And how can I acknowledge that this is how I am? and a part of me, but try my best to use it in a way that doesn't too negatively impact my own sense of self, my own self-worth, the way that I navigate my way through this world. And I think there are many tools that we can use there where we can interrupt our brain pattern, you know, our thought patterns and what we're saying to ourselves around comparison. and we can challenge them, we can be mindful about how we use social media so that, you know,
我们需要说：“你知道，我天生就是一个比较性的生物。”有些人会比其他人更严重。我怎样才能承认这就是我？这是我的一部分，但尽我所能以一种不会太负面地影响我自己的自我意识、我自己的自我价值、我在这个世界上导航的方式来使用它。我认为我们可以在那里使用许多工具，我们可以打断我们的大脑模式，你知道，我们的思维模式以及我们围绕比较对自己说的话。我们可以挑战它们，我们可以对我们如何使用社交媒体保持正念，这样，你知道，
if you are looking on social media repeatedly at people who you compare yourself negatively to, I would call that a self-harm. I would call that a version of self-harm to be doing that, repeatedly, repeatedly, because you are trying to make yourself feel bad and succeeding at making yourself feel bad and that's a matter of like okay how have I developed this habit and what can I replace this with because this is not benefiting me this is not helping me in my own life whatsoever yeah and there's that non-intentional self-harm which can be around for so many of us but that is what it is we are creating our own toxic environment and keeping on lashing that that stick on ourselves and it's just, it's not humane and it's also not necessarily going to help us any closer
如果你在社交媒体上反复看那些你负面比较的人，我会称之为一种自残。我会称之为一种自残的形式，反复地、反复地这样做，因为你是在试图让自己感觉糟糕，并且成功地让自己感觉糟糕，这是一个关于“好吧，我如何养成这个习惯，我可以用什么来代替它”的问题，因为这对我没有好处，这对我自己的生活一点帮助都没有。是的，那种非故意的自残对我们许多人来说可能存在，但这就是它，我们正在创造我们自己的有毒环境，并不断地用那根棍子鞭打自己，这只是，这不人道，而且也不一定能帮助我们更接近
to our goals. And there was a really powerful question in the book that was like, when you're looking at this person or these people and comparing yourself to them, you know, do you actually want their life and all that entails? Can you tell us about that, Lily? Yeah, and it's when I use myself all the time. It's just saying to yourself, okay, I'm looking at this, I'm looking at this amazing holiday and this house and the bag or whatever or that success professional success yes i want some of that and then it's saying okay but do i actually want their entire life do i want their experiences do i want their relationships do i want the way that they treat other people and the way that they operate in through this life and do i want to give up my own do i truly want to give up my own
我们的目标。书中有一个非常有力的问题，就像是：“当你看着这个人或这些人并把自己和他们比较时，你知道，你真的想要他们的生活以及随之而来的一切吗？”你能告诉我们关于那个吗，莉莉？是的，这是我一直对自己用的。这只是对自己说：“好吧，我看着这个，我看着这个很棒的假期、这所房子、这个包或者什么，或者那种成功、职业成功，是的，我想要其中的一些。”然后是说：“好吧，但我真的想要他们的整个生活吗？我想要他们的经历吗？我想要他们的人际关系吗？我想要他们对待别人的方式以及他们在这个生活中运作的方式吗？我想要放弃我自己的吗？我真的想要放弃我自己的
relationships with people and my own experiences and my own ways of being and you know more than nine times out of 10 you know 99 times out of 100 where the answer is no I don't I don't actually want that I want an element of it and then it's working out okay well if I want an element of it what's perhaps even the layer that's a bit deeper than that do I really want that handbag or do I think or is my brain telling me that by having that handbag I'll feel like I've got a bit more status and I'll feel a bit more confident and I'll feel a bit more assured and then it's going okay well if I can't afford that you know what are they called Birkin which you know most most most people in the whole world could not never will insane prices well how can i then work on my
人际关系、我自己的经历和我自己的生活方式吗？”你知道，十次有九次，你知道，一百次有九十九次，答案是“不，我不想要。我并不真的想要那个。我想要其中的一个元素。”然后是弄清楚：“好吧，如果我想要其中的一个元素，什么是比那更深的一层？我真的想要那个手提包吗？还是我的大脑在告诉我，通过拥有那个手提包，我会觉得我有了更多的地位，我会觉得更自信，我会觉得更安心？”然后是去想：“好吧，如果我买不起那个——你知道它们叫什么，铂金包（Birkin），你知道世界上大多数人永远买不起，价格疯狂——好吧，我怎样才能提高我的
confidence how can i work on the feelings that i want that i think that thing will give me whether it's a holiday whether it's a house whether it's a handbag and i'm not saying this is so straightforward because obviously there's like deep inequality in the world that is really unfair and you know I think systemically there needs to be a lot of change in terms of our society. But before that arrives, if that arrives, we have to think, like, how can I better support myself? And how can I look a little bit deeper behind some of those feelings of, like, envy and say, okay, well, how can I turn that into something where I am supporting myself, where I am prioritizing the things that are going to make me feel better? instead of prioritising perhaps the constant comparison. And then when it comes to social media,
自信？我怎样才能处理我想要的那些感觉，那些我认为那件东西会给我的感觉，无论是假期、房子还是手提包？”我并不是说这很简单，因为显然世界上存在深刻的不平等，这非常不公平，你知道，我认为在系统层面上，我们的社会需要有很多改变。但在那到来之前，如果它到来的话，我们必须思考：“我怎样才能更好地支持自己？我怎样才能在那些嫉妒的感觉背后看得更深一点，并说：‘好吧，我怎样才能把它变成一种我支持自己的方式，我优先考虑那些会让我感觉更好的事情？’而不是优先考虑那种持续的比较。”然后当谈到社交媒体时，
I strongly, strongly recommend if you're in that sort of, as you called it, unintentional self-harm spiral around looking at posts and comparing yourself negatively, I strongly recommend resetting your algorithm. And you could, because it's obviously it's going to feed you. If you're looking at the bags or the gym girls or whatever it is
我强烈、强烈建议，如果你处于那种你所说的“非故意自残螺旋”中，围绕着看帖子并负面地比较自己，我强烈建议重置你的算法。你可以，因为显然它会喂养你。如果你在看那些包包、健身女孩或任何东西，
and feeling shit about it, it's going to keep feeding you them and it's going to keep feeding you more and more extreme content around them. So resetting it, Choose a couple of things like nature sounds, you know, cats, whatever it is, buildings, like whatever slightly less emotionally engaging content, and searching that over and over again, clearing out your old search history, and then you'll see that your Discover page at least is just full of that stuff.
并为此感到糟糕，它会不断地喂养你它们，并且它会不断地喂养你更多、更极端的关于它们的内容。所以重置它，选择几样东西，比如自然声音，你知道，猫，无论是什么，建筑物，无论是什么稍微不那么情绪化的内容，并反复搜索它，清除你旧的搜索历史，然后你会发现你的“发现”页面至少全是那些东西。
Perhaps even muting some of the people, if there's friends who don't make you feel very good about yourself right now, muting them for a little while. You know, you don't need to see that content. And that's something I've definitely done myself. If you are struggling with fertility and you've got a bunch of friends who are doing nothing but posting pictures of their kids, you don't have to be the person that's there for them right now.
也许甚至可以屏蔽一些人，如果有些朋友让你现在感觉不太好，那就暂时屏蔽他们。你知道，你不需要看那些内容。这绝对是我自己做过的事情。如果你正在为生育问题而挣扎，而你有一群朋友只会发他们孩子的照片，你不需要现在就去迁就他们。
You don't have to be seeing and liking all their stuff. You are allowed to set a couple of boundaries and step away. You'd be prioritising yourself and you're not wishing them ill harm. You're not saying I don't want you in my life anymore, but this is unintentionally harming me. And that's such a really nice tip for kind of preserving and maintaining and improving your well-being. And you had another one as well. You had an exercise called the Well-Being Cups exercise.
你不必去看并点赞他们的所有内容。你可以设定一些界限并暂时远离。你是在优先考虑自己，而不是希望他们不好。你并不是说我不想再让你出现在我的生活中，而是这在无意中伤害了我。这是一个非常好的建议，可以用来保护、维持和改善你的幸福感。你还有另一个建议，你有一个叫“幸福杯”的练习。
Can you guide us quickly through that one, Lily? It's such a simple one. I love it. It's a, you draw four cups on a piece of paper and they can be any cup you like. It could be a tea cup, could be a wine glass. The first cup is the things that bring me joy and happy. If you like that word, I don't use it so much, but happiness. You've then got a cup that brings you purpose and meaning,
莉莉，你能快速引导我们做一下那个练习吗？它非常简单，我喜欢它。你在一张纸上画四个杯子，它们可以是任何你喜欢的杯子。可以是茶杯，也可以是酒杯。第一个杯子是那些给我带来快乐和幸福的东西。如果你喜欢这个词的话，我不太常用它，但就是幸福。然后你有一个杯子，它给你带来目标和意义，
makes you feel aligned and engaged with this world. And then the other two cups are the things that don't bring you joy and don't bring you purpose. And then you divide all the stuff that goes on in your life, all the people into those cups. And obviously we can't just completely cut out immediately some of the people or things or activities. that don't bring us joy and don't bring meaning. However, it's about seeing like, okay, how can I do more of the stuff that brings me joy and meaning? And how can I empty out a little bit or drink less from those other cups in order to feel more, you know, more like myself and more like I can?
让你感到与这个世界保持一致并参与其中。另外两个杯子是那些不能给你带来快乐和目标的东西。然后你把你生活中的所有事情、所有人都分到这些杯子里。显然，我们不能完全立即切断一些不能给我们带来快乐和意义的人、事或活动。然而，关键在于看看，好吧，我怎样才能做更多能给我带来快乐和意义的事情？我怎样才能清空一点，或者少从那些杯子里喝一点，以便让自己感觉更像自己，感觉自己更有能力？
I've got the resources to navigate this challenging, complex, demanding world. Yeah, and the nature of jobs and the nature of jobs and the nature of. of relationships in the nature of being a parent is that sometimes you might have aspects of that same person or same relationship in multiple cups. Absolutely. Yeah, 100%. There's never just one things are not as simple as dividing them into cups, annoyingly. Yeah, not as black and white. I really, really enjoyed your book, Lily. So it's called Prioritize This and it's by Lily Silverton. I'm assuming it can be accessed to wherever people get their books.
我有资源去应对这个充满挑战、复杂且要求苛刻的世界。是的，工作的性质、人际关系的性质以及作为父母的性质，有时你可能会在多个杯子中拥有同一个人或同一段关系的各个方面。绝对是这样。是的，百分之百。从来没有只有一件事，事情并不像把它们分成杯子那么简单，真烦人。是的，不是那么非黑即白。我非常非常喜欢你的书，莉莉。书名是《优先考虑这个》（Prioritize This），作者是莉莉·西尔弗顿。我想人们可以在任何买书的地方买到它。
Is it also an audio book? Yeah, it's also an audio book. If you didn't mind my voice today, then I'm the one that reads it. If you did, then don't get the audio. It's not a good idea. And yeah, it's all around how to prioritize more helpful ways of thinking or behaving
它有有声书吗？是的，它也有有声书。如果你今天不介意我的声音，那么就是我读的。如果你介意，那就别买有声书。这不是个好主意。是的，它主要讲的是如何在这个现代世界中优先考虑更有帮助的思维或行为方式，
in this modern world, whilst also recognising, I guess, that the world will continue to be itself. So what I found with a lot of self-help books is that they promise the absolute world, And they promise that if you just read this book, then life is going to be perfect. And, you know, this is how it's going to be from now on. And I fundamentally and strongly disagree with that.
同时也认识到，我想，世界将继续保持它原本的样子。我发现很多自助书籍承诺得天花乱坠，它们承诺只要你读了这本书，生活就会变得完美。而且，你知道，从现在开始一切都会变成这样。我从根本上强烈反对这一点。
And so I was trying very much to offer a book that provides the kind of support that goes alongside, you know, incredible psychology work that you guys do. But that really meets people where they're at in their lives and supports them that way. Yeah, I did really enjoy it. So I will definitely leave your review as well. Can people come and follow you on Instagram, Lily? Is that the best place to keep up with you and your work? Yeah, I'm on Lily underscore Silverton on Instagram and I do a bunch of mindset-y stuff type stuff on there. And then I also have a newsletter on Substack, which is the same name as the book, is called Prioritize This.
所以我非常努力地提供一本能够提供支持的书，与你们所做的令人难以置信的心理学工作相辅相成。但它确实是在人们生活的当下与他们相遇，并以那种方式支持他们。是的，我真的很喜欢它。所以我一定会留下你的评论。人们可以去Instagram上关注你吗，莉莉？那是跟进你和你的工作的最佳地点吗？是的，我在Instagram上的账号是Lily_Silverton，我在上面做很多关于心态方面的内容。然后我还在Substack上有一个时事通讯，名字和书名一样，叫《优先考虑这个》（Prioritize This）。
Amazing. I'll pop all the links in the description and in the show notes. But thank you so much for your time. Thank you for writing this book. As I said, I did really enjoy it. and yeah, people can find all the details in the description. Thanks again for your time, Lily. Thank you. Thanks so much for your time in watching or listening to this episode. If it's resonated with you, please do share it to your socials, tag myself, tag Lily in socials. We love to hear from you.
太棒了。我会把所有链接放在描述和节目笔记中。非常感谢你的时间。谢谢你写这本书。正如我所说，我真的很喜欢它。是的，人们可以在描述中找到所有详细信息。再次感谢你的时间，莉莉。谢谢。非常感谢你观看或收听这一集。如果它引起了你的共鸣，请分享到你的社交媒体上，标记我，标记莉莉。我们很乐意听到你的反馈。
And this really does help the show to grow. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. So do come and connect. And let me know if you've got any ideas for future guests or episodes too. Lily and I spoke off camera about both having experienced losing our fathers, especially losing our fathers when we're pregnant with our youngest children. Not an easy thing to do at all. If you have experience of grief or want to understand someone who might be grieving, please do also bear in mind the grief collective book. If you're a big fan of psychology actually, I think you'll also really like the companion podcast series called Inner Work.
这确实有助于节目的成长。我到处都是玛丽安·特伦特博士。所以一定要来联系我。如果你对未来的嘉宾或剧集有任何想法，也请告诉我。莉莉和我在镜头外谈到我们都经历过失去父亲，特别是在我们怀着最小的孩子时失去父亲。这绝非易事。如果你有悲伤的经历，或者想了解可能正在悲伤的人，请也记住《悲伤集体》（The Grief Collective）这本书。如果你是心理学的忠实粉丝，我想你也会非常喜欢配套的播客系列《内在工作》（Inner Work）。
They're all exclusive solo episodes with me. And I explore some of the real life thoughts, reflections, feelings, insights about what it's like to be a psychologist, what it's like for this to crop up in my life, in my work, in my day-to-day, and the reflections, insights, and kind of growth moments that I have as a human and as a professional. I think you'll love it. You can come and grab a free three-day trial on Apple Podcasts. You can also grab a trial on Patreon.
它们都是我和我的独家单人剧集。我探索了一些关于作为一名心理学家的真实想法、反思、感受和见解，关于这在我的生活、工作、日常中出现是什么感觉，以及我作为一个人类和专业人士所拥有的反思、见解和成长时刻。我想你会喜欢的。你可以在Apple Podcasts上获得为期三天的免费试用。你也可以在Patreon上获得试用。
and you can subscribe on YouTube and directly on Captivate. You know that bit after a client session, when you want to grab a drink, maybe make yourself some lunch, perhaps eat your dinner or have some wind down time. But as any clinician knows, when you've still got notes to write up, it can feel hard to get on with your day. And sometimes if it's been a really involved session, it can feel like that bit for each client
你可以在YouTube和Captivate上直接订阅。你知道在客户会话结束后，你想喝杯饮料，也许给自己做点午餐，也许吃晚餐或放松一下。但正如任何临床医生所知，当你还有笔记要写时，继续你的一天可能会感到困难。有时如果这是一个非常投入的会话，感觉每个客户的那部分时间
can turn the 50-minute appointment you'd budgeted for into a 75-minute one. and imagine that on repeat for all of your weekly sessions. Well, this episode is brought to you by WriteUp, and their new A.I. Scribe is a tool built for clinicians who'd quite like their evenings back. Write Up's AI Scribe is your in-session companion, and works whether you're in-person or remote.
可能会把你预算的50分钟预约变成75分钟。想象一下每周所有的会话都这样重复。好吧，这一集是由WriteUp赞助的，他们新的AI记录员是一个为那些想找回晚间时间的临床医生打造的工具。WriteUp的AI记录员是你进行会话时的伴侣，无论你是面对面还是远程工作，它都能发挥作用。
It picks up the clinically relevant details and uses them to draft your clinical notes for you. And the best bit, it'll do it in the structure you usually use. You read, you tweak, You sign off, done. No more, I'll write it up later, guilt spiral at 9pm. Writeup is UK-built, GDPR compliant, and made specifically for healthcare professionals. And because it understands the way we work, not just the way American systems work,
它会捕捉临床相关的细节，并用它们为你起草临床笔记。最棒的部分是，它会以你通常使用的结构来完成。你阅读、调整、签字，完成。不再有晚上9点那种“我以后再写”的内疚感。WriteUp是英国制造的，符合GDPR标准，专为医疗保健专业人员制作。因为它了解我们的工作方式，而不仅仅是美国系统的工作方式，
I think that like me, you're going to love it. Right now, you can grab your free 30-day trial of write-up, which includes a four-hour free trial with AI scribe. Then you can see how it handles your notes before you commit to it. to anything. Head to writeup.com to give it a go. That's W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P-com. And remember to use the code Marianne 30. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我想你会像我一样喜欢它。现在，你可以获得WriteUp的30天免费试用，其中包括4小时的AI记录员免费试用。然后你可以在承诺购买之前看看它如何处理你的笔记。前往writeup.com试用一下。网址是W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P.com。记得使用代码Marianne 30。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。